every day I wake up now every single day
someone has either announced they are
running for president or they've made a
big announcement that they are not
running for president yeah it's been a
lot of knocks it's been a lot of knots
which they didn't used to be the case
it's just that now so many people are
running that you have to physically
announce that you are not running for
president
it's very strange it's time we're living
in speaking of not running former New
York City Mayor Michael Bloomberg
announced he is not running for
president that was his big announcement
he says he's not running not running not
running Bloomberg said the last thing
this country needs is another mega rich
guy from New York with his name on
everything now that's funny cuz Trump is
a rich guy from New York with his name
on everything so that's why that jokes
funny I get a check either way ladies
and gentlemen we can play this the nice
way or we can play it the hard way
this shows free I don't know what your
problem is it's too bad he's not running
no I was looking forward to Bloomberg's
campaign slogan I actually am a
billionaire I thought that was
[Music]
[Applause]
oh it's very unusual you get this many
people who are all pro billionaire let's
go easy on the money right two things
penis size and billionaire you can't
touch either one of those grateful for
one of those this week Hillary Clinton
said she will not run the president
again she's not gonna run as a result
Fox News is down to one minute of daily
programming the rest is all catheter ads
I believe it is I'm sorry what
excuse me don't with this crowd is
remote hey watch CNN right right this is
where I mean Fox I'm sorry Fox you can
watch CNN too but watch Fox for how long
would you say what are you gonna see ads
for you're gonna see those reverse
mortgages yeah mesothelium mesothelioma
suing for that and and catheters yeah
you know like let's see I put a new
catalyst to and cialis are exactly
erectile dysfunction yeah we know what
cialis is for
trust me we know what